look I don't have a brown pinstripe suit
I don't have a blue suit
I don't even ever write color shirt yet
but I do have the tie I'll get there
[Applause]
[Music]
new earth here we go
taking off series 2 in my overdue Doctor
Who review you know going back through
the ones that I had don't already have
videos up which means I get to do the
entirety of the fourth the Tenth Doctor
god I should I should just start over
Tennant the Fourth Doctor also almost
all of Matt Smith so here we go new
earth an episode that I have had unkind
words to say about in the past so how do
we go forward here
well Tennant himself pretty much grabs
the character right off the bat it's
actually funny going back and knowing
how things sort of go for him further on
down the line I don't think I'd clocked
how early on his arrogance and his sort
of self-importance was on display you
know the things that would have
eventually pay off with the with the
whole time Lord triumphant thing I
forgot how early that stuff showed up
cuz it's pretty much right off the bat
you know the whole thing with him
confronting a nun and saying I'm the
doctor if you're looking for a higher
authority there isn't one of my Wow
really and that again I mean that's kind
of a jump up even like for Michaelson
especially because that custom was kind
of you know he didn't want a part of
this anymore whereas the doctors like
you will shut it down because I said so
not even like because I'll stop you but
because I said so so like I've forgotten
how early that stuff showed up another
thing that is actually really good here
and it's worth noting now is his
chemistry with Rose now what's
interesting is there there are
advantages and disadvantages to having a
companion remain once we get a doctor
regeneration so we have a
you know companion as the carryover
through line for a new doctor the
benefit is we don't have to be trying to
get to know a new doctor at the same
time we're trying to get to know a new
companion to give us a stronger sense of
continuity that is the advantage the
disadvantage is is that you're
immediately going to be comparing the
dynamic and the chemistry between this
companion and the previous doctor and
the one that came after for better or
worse and usually someone's going to
come off the worst from that I mean even
if I stick to modern era I you know I am
NOT especially looking forward to
Clara's time with Smith because I think
she had much better performance
chemistry with Capaldi than she did with
Smith but what's interesting about this
is that Rose had really not only had
very good chemistry performance
chemistry and remember when I say
chemistry doesn't necessarily mean
romantic and performance chemistry with
Eccleston and also with Tennant and at
the same time it's a very different kind
of chemistry between each of them
because it does lean flirtier with a
tenant but it is still a very potent
chemistry and that actually like props
off too props off hats off and props -
I'm on a roll tonight Billie Piper for
having a different dynamic that still
has that same feel of connection between
her and the other actor that that helps
quite a bit that might be it for
positive stuff or at least wholly
positive because I mean there's a number
there there are things that I've
remembered not like he bought new earth
and then there was stuff that I forgot I
didn't like about it so I mean there's
the cat people which look I don't you
don't have to tell me oh it's the ideas
that they've evolved from cats like I
understand where they come from I like
it's not that I don't get it is that
it's a really really really really lazy
creature design let's just take this
animal that we know and now it's a
person now that's just that's really
lazy and I
really don't like that as a creature
design element and I don't care if you
narratively justify it I don't like it
so that doesn't help the eye you know
what there is some interesting things
going on with the dynamic of what the
sisters are doing as sort of their
attitude about it and I kind of wish
that was something that got explored a
bit more like the this whole notion of
the ways they've rationalized that it's
okay that what they're doing is OK and I
kind of wish we delved into that a
little bit more rather than just having
them be the straight-up villains who
obviously just bought into all this and
our lost causes I kind of wish that we
we spent a little bit more time with
their justification than the
rationalizations that basically the way
they go to bed at night because I feel
like there was some there's some depth
to be mine there that you know a little
bit of a missed opportunity Cassandra is
kind of a mixed bag first off actually
both Tennant and Piper do a really good
job of embodying her performance and
which is not an easy thing to do it's
not a it's not an easy thing to you know
be a dude to basically be sort of
playing a character that isn't a carrot
that's a character somebody else already
established in the body of a character
you're usually playing like that's and
that's not easy and they both they both
quit themselves pretty well on that
front and I do like the final moments
with Cassandra with you know her in the
body of the person who had been her
servant you know and going back and
seeing herself at a younger age when she
had you know an actual
standard human body that is a really
nice moment Cassandra coming back in
general is kind of contrived and random
and I'm not sure it does much like aside
from give us that moment I do think that
actually they also they did build up to
that moment
well as well because I think the the
idea of her temporarily present
possessing one of the diseased humans
and feeling all of their pain in the
brief time she was there and everything
that had been done to them would have a
very severe impact on her so I mean that
that worked pretty well I think the
solution is stupid as hell like what
they have every disease which is a
little bit of a weird concept in the
first place so what do we do poor every
medicine into a vat and spray it spray
them with it what yeah cuz that's how
medicine works like aside from the fact
that I would have to assume at least
some of the diseases that they have must
be stuff they don't have cures for yet
otherwise why would they keep doing this
if they had a cure for literally
everything that these that these
infected people have there had to be
something like it's it's it's this
oversimplified just chizel II
implemented an idea that like doesn't
work like on a logistics level at all so
like I don't like that resolution
the face of BOE thing is just kind of
there it's basically a placeholder to
remind you hey here's the face of BOE
will pay this off later and that's kind
of all it does another thing that I
forgot that the doctor that this doctor
brings up is is that is the little shop
a little gift shop like I remember that
being a thing in in series four with at
the library and I forgot that he brought
it up here so it that's what it's those
little moments that can be very fun when
you go back and revisit these things too
despot these when you didn't before but
yeah overall it's just and like you you
opened the episode you tease with where
we're going farther than we've ever gone
before it's new
so technically we're not on earth
anymore but you got to bring us to a
place that was built to remember earth
as much as possible like can we just can
we have some weird alien as' maybe
please
so like the there there are little
moments there are little things and then
in the performances of the core cast are
all good in this episode but there's
just a lot of things that uh that bugged
the heck out of me and it's largely like
lazy detailing like the the the way it's
resolved I think is a lazy solution the
aliens I think our lazy concept the just
having the the nuns be flat-out villains
like oh well they're okay doing this to
these humans that they've convinced
themselves aren't even real people that
means she'll also she's also willing to
tear apart a conscious human being with
her claws I'm like well no you could
have gone for nuance there you took the
lazy route again and that's sort of my
annoyance with this episode I'm actually
thinking on it now there's there's gonna
be a lot of stumbling blocks in series 2
series 2 has some of my favorite stories
some of my favorite individual episodes
but it's got a lot of rut stuff it's
also got some of my least favorite ever
so this is gonna be a very up-and-down
stretch for a little bit but that's new
earth what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do such as you know click buttons
and links there's one to my patreon if
you feel like helping fund me get the
proper outfit no I actually trying to
use those funds to do more meaningful
things like maybe upgrade the camera and
things like that but if you don't want
to do that that's ok there's other links
to check out as well don't want to click
on those that's fine too because at the
end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]